foreign
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah in the country of
Norway click on the link and donate now
for the sake of Allah scrolling on
Instagram today and I came across this
amazing video of thousands of Swedish
Muslims coming together to recite the
Quran I found it so profound just listen
to this guys and this Quran burners
think that they are burning the Quran
how are you going to burn hundreds if
not millions billions of Muslims who
know the Quran step by step brothers and
sisters how are you going to burn them
you filthy scum who are who's burning
the Quran to get a passport you're going
to lose this life in the Hereafter
inshallah and these most of these
individuals are dying one of them took
his own life why because they are
depressed they are unhappy and they are
only burning and consuming their self
look at this beautiful recitation
inshallah and we're going to come back
[Music]
while you shall live
many goodness
[Music]
so you guys saw that for yourself it
wasn't that beautiful thousands of
Swedish Muslims coming together to
recite the Quran and you know what Allah
says in the Quran strive with them with
what does Allah say jihadun the greater
Jihad which The Scholar says what it's
the Quran we must still don't need
Atomic weapons weapons of mass
destruction Jihad Etc none of that just
let us talk let us preach that is the
only greatest weapon a Muslim believer
has the Kalam the uncreated speech of
Allah the ever living subhanallah let us
do that and Nations will come to Islam
all their effort is time is bad it's
time as they start look at their efforts
just going to ruins how because most
people are coming to istan why because
of his intolerance yes
Islam is intolerant two certain ways of
life it's as simple as that and brothers
and sisters we're going to use this hate
like the brothers and sisters will
recite in the Quran to build massaging
to print qurans
printed 100 000 translations of the
Quran in Swedish how many people are
going to come to Islam carry on doing it
you think you can get rid of the Quran
by burning it it's in our hearts
millions of us what are you gonna do
when all of us come on my friend you
little weasel
weaseline do not forget to check ustad
admin Rashid is doing them taught in
Islamic Spain Istanbul is Spain for 700
years you guys should go and see the
Heritage the history of Islam and he's
got a one-time uh only subpanic limited
spaces left for that tour like going
this month I would have loved to go them
a little bit busy but on the next one
I'm not missing out inshallah brothers
and sisters please please make sure
check that out and donate to Mr in
Norway and also checklist is going to I
urge every single one of you guys to go
and get a glimpse of that he's an
historian Rashid please enjoy this
inshallah and check that out inshallah
till next time
is raising funds to establish a Masjid
and Community Center in Norway and they
urgently need your support every person
who prays there every kid that learns
about Islam every youngster that
memorized the Quran all of this and so
much more can be only a scale of Good
Deeds click the link and donate what you
can and share the video for even extra
reward